bonsoir et bienvenue dans savon garde
ravi de vous retrouver au sommaire ce
soir la chasse aux électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est ouvert avec ses 22% des
voix au premier tour l'insoumis se
retrouvent en position d'arbitre pour le
second tour Macron Le Pen ou abstention
que feront ces électeurs le 24 avril
prochain déjà les deux finalistes font
des gestes importants sur leur programme
alors jusqu'où sont-ils prêts à faire
des concessions on en parle dans un
instant dans notre grand débat sur ce
plateau notre grand témoin ce soir à
passer sa vie à essayer de comprendre
comment les peuples pouvaient se laisser
embrigader entraîner dans des crimes de
masse son histoire intime celle d'un
enfant juif de déporté arrêté puis caché
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale se
réveille devant l'horreur des crimes
russes commis en Ukraine comment vivre
avec ces images qui reviennent que faire
du sentiment d'impuissance ou de
culpabilité il publie le laboureur et
les mangeurs devant le neuropsychiatre
Boris Cyrulnik est avec nous ce soir
enfin ce sera le scan comme tous les
soirs avec jean-rébine Baudot qui passe
au crible ce soir la nouvelle affiche de
campagne de Marine Le Pen et puis l'oeil
de Blacko bien sûr le carnet de campagne
quotidien signé Stéphane blackovski
voilà pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous cherchez les
spectateurs c'est une réserve de voies
très importante et très convoité près de
8 millions d'électeurs ont choisi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dimanche dernier
alors où vont-ils aller ces électeurs
qui vont-ils préférer la main tendue de
Marine Le Pen ou celle des manuels
Macron bonsoir Céline Calvez bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
député la République en marche sortante
des Hauts de Seine bonsoir manuel
Bompard bienvenue député européen vous
avez dirigé la campagne présidentielle
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec nous à
distance ce soir depuis Lens Emmanuel
bléri bonsoir vous êtes bien là député
rassemblement national du Pas-de-Calais
député aussi qui remet en jeu son mandat
et bonsoir Éric Le Boucher bonsoir
Myriam ravi de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau vous êtes éditorialiste aux
échos et à l'opinion et vous venez de
publier échec à la barbarie c'est un
essai passionnant chez Grasset sur la
montée des populismes sur leur ressort
mais c'est assez aussi optimiste sur la
suite on va en parler je l'espère au
cours de ce débat je vais vous donner la
parole mais on va faire d'abord le point
en images sur ce duel à distance
Emmanuel Macron dans le grand est
aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen en Normandie
avec une même obsession convaincre les
mélenchonistes Marco pommier
Emmanuel Macron infléchit sa position
sur la réforme des retraites depuis de
jours le président candidat se dit prêt
à faire quelques concessions l'horizon
de 65 ans dommage de Galles à horizon
2031 peut tout à fait être adapté on
peut on peut tout à fait imaginer des
clauses de revoyure un changement de cap
sur une réforme qui inquiète hier à
Denain pour son premier déplacement de
l'entrée de Tours Emmanuel Macron était
régulièrement interpellé sur la question
la retraite 65 ans
à 60 ans les gens décèdent de fatigue
etc ceux qui ont travaillé à l'extérieur
mais vous voulez que je vous dise donc
on en est malade de votre réforme on va
progressivement
ajouter trois quatre mois par année
faire de la pédagogie sur une mesure qui
reste un totem pour l'électorat
populaire Emmanuel Macron le sait alors
pour conquérir les électeurs de gauche
surtout ceux de Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
président sortant dit vouloir compléter
son projet pour rassembler il faut
pouvoir sur des sujets comme l'écologie
le travail entendre aussi des voix qui
ont été portées avec beaucoup de clarté
même combat chez Marine Le Pen pour
convaincre à gauche la candidate du
rassemblement national annonce
aujourd'hui une révolution référendaire
dans son quinquennat un concept cher à
l'électorat de Jean-Luc Mélenchon je
compte donc par une pratique apaisée et
renouvelée du référendum instaurer une
nouvelle pratique démocratique qui ne
fera pas dépendre de la seule élection
présidentielle toutes les décisions pour
les années à venir pour séduire Marine
Le Pen se présente aussi comme la
candidate du pouvoir d'achat avec un
programme social en déplacement dans
l'Yonne hier chez un AG céréalier elle
accusait Emmanuel Macron de ne pas
anticiper les crises liées à l'inflation
au-delà de l'augmentation du gaz du
fioul de l'électricité
et du carburant auquel les Français sont
confrontés aujourd'hui il y a un autre
nuage noir qui arrive sur la tête des
Français et qui va être l'inflation des
prix de l'alimentation pour Marine Le
Pen l'équation est compliquée dimanche
le troisième homme de cette campagne a
appelé à ne donner aucune voie à la
candidate du rassemblement national
alors je vais commencer par le plus
draguer ces choses dire sur ce plateau
ce soir manuel bon pas comment vous
regardez ce qui se passe avec vos
électeurs au fond est-ce que ça vous
agace passer des heures on les a vu les
deux aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen et
Emmanuel Macron des heures sur le
terrain à tondre la main à essayer de
convaincre vos électeurs ça vous agace
ou c'est le jeu au fond d'une élection à
deux tours c'est une campagne
présidentielle c'est un deuxième tour il
y a deux candidats qui sont en lice il
est normal que ces candidats essaient de
s'adresser à l'ensemble des Françaises
et des Français donc non ça ne m'agace
pas maintenant ce qui peut m'agacer
c'est que au-delà des déclarations et de
la communication je trouve que les
engagements qui sont pris ou les
propositions ou les ouvertures qui sont
faites manquent
énormément de clarté ça veut dire que
vous attendez au fond quand même un
geste sur le fond c'est pas simplement
s'élargir en tendant la main des
électeurs mais il faut qu'il y ait
vous pourriez vouloir des concessions de
programmes programmatique non moi je
n'attends rien puisque Jean-Luc
convention
de l'élection présidentielle donc
maintenant c'est aux différents
candidats de faire de faire leur
campagne mais si on pense par exemple
reprendre l'exemple qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure qu'on va convaincre les
électrices et les électeurs qui se sont
portés sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon en disant
que au lieu d'aller à 65 ans l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 64 ans je pense
qu'on est à peu près à côté du sujet
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a dit pas une voix
pour Marine Le Pen manuel bon par vous
irez voter le 24
pour moi et je peux dire
Marine Le Pen vous voterez Macron mais
pourquoi vous savez qui quand on vote
aussi décidé de voter blanc certains
peut-être n'iront pas voter non mais je
vais pas vous dire ici pourquoi je vais
voter mais pas pas bien pourquoi je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi parce que parmi
l'ensemble des électrices et des
électeurs qu'on va apporter leur voix
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a des gens qui
ont des avis différents sur ce qu'il
faut faire au deuxième tour il y a une
position qui est une position de
principe qui est la note qui est très
claire c'est pas une voix pour Madame Le
Pen mais on est plus autant des
consignes aujourd'hui donc pas une voix
pour Madame Le Pen c'est une borne et
ensuite dans cette borne là chacun fait
18 semble oui c'est la densité le vote
le vote blanc ou Emmanuel Macron
c'est-à-dire consultation qui sera
organisée parmi les différentes
personnes comparer la candidature de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour dire qu'elle
leur point de vue sur le sujet alors
c'est l'une Calvez on voudrait
comprendre exactement l'état d'esprit du
président candidat pour présenter sur ce
plateau allez convaincre ça il adore
faire ça ça y est il est dans le costume
c'est sûr de candidat mais est-ce qu'il
faut changer
évoluer sur le fond sur le programme et
si oui quoi déjà il faut se poser la
question de pourquoi il y a eu cette
mobilisation et c'était électorat pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon moi je sais que
Clichy dans la circonscription on a vu
des personnes qu'on n'avait pas vu lors
des cinq dernières années sur les
scrutins donc on doit dire ben merci
d'avoir ramené des gens aux urnes après
ce n'est pas forcément des voix qui ont
été au premier tour à Emmanuel Macron
mais c'est des personnes qui se sont de
nouveau intéressés à la vie politique
alors certains d'entre eux ont pu le
faire par pleine conviction pour les
propositions de la France insoumise et
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'autres parfois
avec des stratégies se sont dit je vais
voter Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour éviter que
le deuxième se soit Marine Le Pen et
donc du coup ce sera plus facile pour
Emmanuel Macron de battre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
je vais vous dire ah si assez
franchement j'ai pu en faire part à ma
réunion de groupe hier je me suis dit
mais finalement cette nouvelle
l'apparition d'un électorat pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je parlais Clichy
c'est 42% Jean-Luc Mélenchon je dis bah
chouette on va pouvoir mettre en lumière
davantage
en fait déjà déjà de se dire que on
porte à la connaissance de toutes et de
tout ce qui est ce que sont les bilans
est-ce que sont les propositions ça fait
mouche encore dimanche après-midi de
pouvoir discuter avec des soutiens alors
là pour le coup la France insoumise
convaincue c'est de se dire mais
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre
au crédit de ce quinquennat et bien les
classes des doubler en repérer plus
comme on en a beaucoup ici en région
parisienne et bien ça il faut le
reconnaître et ce n'est pas encore assez
sucre ça profite à 330 pour l'état
d'esprit on va rentrer dans le détail
mais les propositions le versement
automatique des aides qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier à toute une part de la
population qui ne connaît même pas mais
la solidarité on explique mieux le bilan
et on explique mieux le projet le
programme forcément des évolutions
l'évolution l'évolution vous le savez en
fait le non le fond il comporte aussi
quelque chose d'important c'est de dire
qu'en terme de méthode la porte est déjà
découverte sur les chantiers de la santé
chantier de l'école à ce qu'il y ait une
concertation s'il doit y en avoir une
sur la retraite et surtout de pouvoir
rappeler que on n'est pas que sur un âge
c'est pas ça c'est on préserve la
répartition on fait une retraite minimum
à 1100 euros pour des carrières
complètes et on va évoluer sur les
prises en compte des pénibilités c'est
aussi ça donc moi je pense que c'est
l'occasion d'expliquer davantage ce que
c'est et après et après on peut évoluer
mais déjà au sein
même question Emmanuel bléri pour être
très précis sur quoi vous pourriez
bouger pour réussir au fond à capter ou
à convaincre les électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
écoutez déjà d'emblée je souhaite quand
même vous dire que le volet social dans
le programme de Marine Le Pen il est là
il est clairement affiché il est solide
on parlait là de la retraite
donc cette retraite non la proposons à
60 ans pour ceux qui ont commencé tôt
donc ceux qui commencent au généralement
ce sont eux qui ont des métiers assez
difficiles mais pourquoi aujourd'hui
évoluer changer j'ai vu le président
candidat se déplaçait là et sur ma
circonscription et puis dans un autre
département
il est en train de prendre le pouls et
de peut-être de reficeler un peu son son
programme nous nous avons le volet
social crédible en matière de pouvoir
d'achat en matière de de retraite on
disait donc je nous voilà on a le
programme social au pouvoir d'achat
j'entends bien bon en tout cas vous êtes
à peu près pareil on a l'impression du
côté de Emmanuel Macron du côté de
Marine Le Pen c'est d'abord notre
programme le bilan pour Macron puis
éventuellement je voudrais vous montrer
les ce qu'on appelle les vases commun et
c'est très frappant parce que là en cinq
ans ça a beaucoup évolué Eric Le Boucher
c'est ipso 5 qui a bien calculé au fond
les c'était vraiment un tiers un tiers
1/3 vous avez
36% qui sont tentés soit par le vote
blanc nul ou abstention on parle
évidemment des électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui hésitent encore 34 % votre
Emmanuel Macron 30% pour pour Marine Le
Pen là on est sur quelque chose de
beaucoup plus important dans les vases
communicants Mélenchon Le Pen par
rapport à l'élection il y a 5 ans
comment vous l'expliquer
écoutez j'ai fait pas mal de
statistiques donc quand on a des
résultats 30-30 ça veut dire que les
Français savent pas c'est ça que ça veut
dire d'abord donc en fait je pense que
c'est trop tôt les Français ne savent
pas pour qui enfin de de la France
insoumise ne savent pas très bien enfin
une partie c'est sans doute mais ne
savent pas très bien pour qu'ils vont
voter je crois que les 15 jours qui
viennent sont essentiels de ce point de
vue donc c'est 30% qui pourraient voter
Marine Le Pen venant de chez Mélenchon
vous pensez que c'est mal évalué c'est
trop tôt pour le pour le moment
pour cent qui ont voté pour Monsieur
Mélenchon il y en a 10 qui venaient de
la gauche traditionnelle de la gauche
plutôt sociale démocrate qui est logique
et qui voulait que c'était le vote utile
qui voulait que la gauche existe bon ben
voilà la gauche ça existe ça elle fait
22 %, mais au deuxième tour évidemment
je pense que c'est 10% là dans la
logique vont plutôt voter pour Emmanuel
Macron franchement parce que parce que
Le Pen c'est l'horreur absolue pour eux
donc je voyais on se trompe un peu tous
les chiffres je crois que c'est trop tôt
encore pour connaître exactement et
d'ailleurs ce sera difficile parce que
les gens vont se déterminer
tentés par Marine Le Pen vous n'êtes pas
convaincus de ça s'il y en a plus ça
c'est il y en a plus qu'à ça c'est
certain parce qu'il y en a qui sont
horripilés par la personne de d'Emmanuel
Macron
ou ses fameux populisme puisque il
revendique chacun à leur manière plutôt
radical de gauche plutôt droite de la
droite voire droite nationaliste je
crois vous avez dans tous les pays
développés c'est dégagé une poussée
populiste qui est que représente en gros
maintenant les deux tiers des gens
populistes de gauche peuplés de droite
et en face vous avez une élite ou un
centre qui vaut 30% c'est pour ça qu'on
retrouve les 30-30 mais là pour le coup
sur les votes pas sur les intentions de
vote et donc ce populisme là ça
représente deux tiers des gens donc qui
ont le sentiment d'être malheureux c'est
ça le populisme aujourd'hui alors c'est
un sentiment ce n'est pas toujours vrai
c'est assez vrai aux États-Unis beaucoup
moins vrai en Europe très peu vrai en
France mais c'est le sentiment qui
compte ils ont la peur d'être déclassé
ils ont la peur de voir l'essence
augmenter ils ont peur de devenir prof
c'est cette peur qui est qui joue sur le
fond des programmes et notamment la
question des retraites mais vous êtes
aussi un journaliste économique très
affûté quel est le d'un point de vue
économique quel est le programme le plus
proche de celui de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
d'un point de vue économique non mais ni
l'un ni l'autre en vérité parce que les
deux sont des programmes magiques oui
c'est ça la difficulté de Macron s'est
dit il doit pas question
de celui de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
des cadeaux ils ne pensent redistribuer
le programme chiffré mais non mais
la protection
[Musique]
c'est le nouveau truc des candidats
populistes on a chiffré mais bon d'abord
il faudrait voir les chiffres mais c'est
pas le sujet de dire que c'est pas le
cas
c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est le
sujet fondamental c'est qu'on ne
redistribue c'est des programmes de
redistribution on aurait distribue que
ce qu'on produit or les deux détruisent
la production Madame Le Pen elle va le
faire très rapidement et Monsieur
Mélenchon l'aurait fait rapidement
donc les deux sont c'est ça la
difficulté de Macron c'est de draguer en
effet comme vous avez dit un électorat
d'extrême gauche ou un hectorax et
reporté sur Mélenchon à 100 totalement
lui dire je prends toutes vos positions
elles sont elles sont pas réalistes il
va pas les prendre une chose qui a pu
surprendre c'est qu'on avait cru
comprendre que les 65 ans et j'arrive
sur les retraites était devenu vraiment
un marqueur de la campagne de premier
tour d'Emmanuel Macron manuel bon pas
les choses peuvent évoluer qu'est-ce que
vous avez compris vous précisément puis
ensuite on demandera à Sénégal parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'au fond ça n'est
plus un tabou et que au cours d'une
négociation sociale l'âge de départ
pourrait bouger à 64 moi j'ai rien
compris je veux juste d'abord répondre
de deux éléments premièrement le sondage
que vous avez cité 30-30 excusez-moi il
y en a un autre ce matin qui dit 12% de
des électeurs de Jean
d'âge donc ce que je suis d'accord enfin
franchement tout ça ne veut rien dire et
si j'ai un peu de mémoire
le seul premier tour de l'élection de
2017 on disait que 30% de l'électorat de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon allait voter pour
Marion
vous vous appuyez sur un sondage et je
suis en train de vous dire qu'il y a un
autre sondage qui dit exactement
l'inverse et je vous dis que après
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 on
disait exactement la même chose avec
exactement les mêmes chiffres et à la
fin il y a 7 % des électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon convoité pour Marine Le Pen au
deuxième tour donc vous vous croyez pas
mais c'est la communication vous pensez
que
marginal après est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
des non mais je vais vous répondre après
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des électeurs
qui à un moment ce pose la question
aujourd'hui de voter pour Madame Le Pen
oui il y en a sans aucun doute et il y
en a sans aucun doute pour une raison
simple parce que ils ont beaucoup
souffert pendant les cinq années qui
viennent de s'écouler ils ont eu
l'impression d'être méprisé ils ont eu
l'impression d'être maltraité et ils ont
l'impression que le programme d'Emmanuel
Macron ne répondait pas à leur
difficulté sociale et et malheureusement
dans les propositions et le programme
que porte aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron
pour le prochain quinquennat ils ont
toujours ce sentiment là et donc
effectivement ils veulent chasser
Emmanuel Macron du pouvoir et donc
certains vont jusqu'à ce qui me paraît
être une erreur c'est à dire comparer du
bulletin de vote de Marine Le Pen pour
le faire et moi je leur ai dit
clairement je peux comprendre que vos
ressentiez ça mais je pense que vous
vous trompez si vous faites ça parce que
le Marine Le Pen ne va pas résoudre les
problèmes sur les retraites comment vous
prenez au fond ce bouger comme on dit en
politique vous dites donc on a ce
pouvoir là ou de rien compris non j'ai
pas compris et je pense que si je ne
demande rien Emmanuel Macron mais si
Emmanuel Macron veut convaincre les
électrices et les électeurs qui ont qui
se sont portés sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui ne m'appartiennent pas d'ailleurs et
qui n'appartiennent pas à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon non plus hein qui
n'appartiennent à personne si vous les
convaincre va falloir faire un peu mieux
que des petits artifices de
communication qui sont pas très
convaincants alors qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui peut bouger sur les
retraites mais je pense que c'est
important qu'on clarifie les choses là
parce que un 65 ans ça a parlé à un
électorat en français à la droite en
particulier et on a l'impression qu'on a
juste une du ce chiffre en fait 65 et
qu'on a oublié ce que je rappelais tout
à l'heure quels sont les paramètres de
cette réforme le président candidat mais
il a il a une évolution possible mais il
a à chaque fois rappeler que on gardait
un système par répartition n'oublions
pas c'est quand même un engagement fort
pour la solidarité intergénérationnelle
français
pénibilité parce que travailler de nuit
c'est pas du tout la même chose et c'est
pas même l'usure de des hommes et des
femmes qui le pratiquent mais surtout on
oublie aussi
un tabou c'est c'est clair on
casse il faut qu'on comprenne exactement
parce que c'est pas clair mais pour moi
pour moi surtout ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui on part en moyenne 63 ans et
demi et que l'idée est de dire bon bah
on va aller progressivement quatre mois
en par an à considérer que on va
travailler plus mais pour autant on va
pas se dire que quelqu'un qui a commencé
à travailler à 28 ans il va s'arrêter à
60 tout le monde a bien compris que pour
les carrières longues la pénibilité tout
le monde a bien compris mais là je les
garde c'est très important on voit bien
aujourd'hui que on s'est tellement
focalisé sur l'âge qu'on a l'impression
que c'était uniquement ça qui comptait
donc on a l'impression que quand on
bouge en disant oui bah peut-être que le
rythme avec lequel on va allonger la
durée d'atteinte de l'âge légal
peut-être que c'est pas 4 mois peut-être
que c'est trois mois cinq Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas fait exprès de dire 65
ans avant le premier tour
je sais pas maintenant téléguidé ou pas
mais en tout cas ce que montre les enfin
les déplacements diarrhée d'aujourd'hui
c'est dire que non seulement le enfin le
candidat a montré dans 5 ans sa capacité
à décider mais il montre aussi sa
capacité à écouter et quand on s'engage
pour être alors non pas dans une
révolution référendaire mais dans une
démocratie délibérative qui a été mis en
place durant ce quinquennat avec la
convention citoyenne on pourrait
imaginer c'est d'ailleurs ça a été
proposé sur la fin de vie mais qu'on
puisse le faire sous davantage de forme
le référendum pourquoi pas et encore
faut-il bien le préparer et je le répète
et puisque on est à LCP c'est que aussi
cette forme de démocratie elle vient
compléter la démocratie représentative
que les députés que ça soit européen ou
français on incarne on n'est pas en
train d'opposer mais en train de
compléter cette méthode donc on décide
on écoute avant de décider mais on n'est
pas obligé non plus de dire que on
reviendrait un bouger non en fait une
méthode toujours on écoute on va voir
jusqu'où en tout cas on est allé à
Montreuil qui a voté à plus de 50 % pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dimanche dernier leur
poser la question au fond qu'est-ce que
vous allez voter et puis qu'avez-vous
compris tiens sur sur les retraites
est-ce que ça pourrait vous faire voter
Macron regardez c'est un reportage
d'Alex Guillaume
à Montreuil ou Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
arrivé en tête avec plus de 55% des voix
au premier tour comment les dernières
déclarations d'Emmanuel Macron sur la
retraite ont-elles été perçue par les
électeurs de la France insoumise pour
Christelle cette bataille sur l'âge de
la retraite la laisse plutôt
indifférente j'ai l'impression que oui
qu'on essaie de d'alpaguer les derniers
sur un chiffre clé 60 64 enfin chacun
comme c'est du Loto quoi et moi j'ai
vraiment que la l'impression que la
retraite c'est du Loto toute façon je
verrai en fonction de qui sera au
pouvoir à ce moment-là ce qui décidera
pour mon pour mon sort mais bon c'est
pas ça qui va me faire changer d'avis en
tout cas et en plus j'y crois pas enfin
sur le chiffre qui va être annoncé là de
toute façon j'y crois pas le
rétropédalage d'Emmanuel Macron a en
tout cas convaincu Moussa qui votera
donc pour le chef de l'État il a oublié
il n'a pas le choix
renfermé il voyait pas beaucoup de
beaucoup de réalité mais maintenant ça
va pour Victor jeune informaticien la
retraite c'est bien trop loin pour
influencer son bulletin de la semaine
prochaine je serai à la retraite on aura
changé cinq six fois de président
j'espère ils auront fait 6 ou 7 fois des
promesses qui ne tiendront pas donc j'ai
envie de vous dire pour le moment j'ai
mis questionne pas trop là il y a aussi
ceux qui sont désabusés Yves pour la
première fois de sa vie pense voter
blanc
oui madame Le Pen adoucit son discours
mais sur le fond ça reste exactement la
même chose et Macron a dit à 5 ans je
serai de droite et de gauche il a été de
droite et de droite on l'a bien vu et là
il est prêt à bouger un peu bah oui
c'est juste si c'est Pinocchio quoi qui
nous parle c'est c'est
électoraliste et c'est totalement
insérant voilà donc c'est pas
intéressant et c'est pas séduisant de
toute façon à 42 ans ou Ahmed a voté
pour la première fois seulement cette
année il avait enfin trouvé son candidat
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et s'il a voté pour
quelqu'un en premier tour il ne votera
pas contre au deuxième le 24 avril il
s'absiendra
c'est la peste écolière quoi c'est dire
autant rester à la maison ne pas voter
pas blanc abstention j'aimerais bien
qu'on arrive à 50% en abstention ça
serait bien voilà c'est pas gagné en
tout cas pour les électeurs de Montreuil
on le voit bien Éric Le Boucher sur
cette question des retraites comment
vous vous analysez au fond c'est les
différentes annonces ça fait je sais pas
la cinquième réforme des retraites qu'on
fait de depuis 25 ans c'est toujours
dans le même sens c'est-à-dire que les
gens vivent de plus en plus longtemps
donc il faut qu'ils travaillent de plus
en plus longtemps si on veut équilibrer
le système de retraite et non pas
baisser les retraites c'est un problème
extrêmement simple donc c'est un
problème de calcul des de l'argent qui
rentre de l'argent qui sort donc alors
il a fixé 65 ans comme ça c'est une
norme et si je vous rappelle en 2030 si
j'ai compris donc c'est quand même on
est en 22 c'est dans 8 ans donc
effectivement suivant les calculs de
lâcher au lendemain du premier tour un
autre une autre borne ou en tout cas
vous apporte sa stratégie c'est de dire
il faut fixer une barre pour que les
Français comprennent qu'il faut
travailler plus c'est ça son idée de
plus et il a raison il faut que les
Français travaillent plus ça c'est une
certitude parce que on travaille moins
que les Allemands et du coup on
s'appauvrit par rapport aux Allemands
bon donc et le premier terrain sur
lequel on peut travailler plus c'est
travailler plus long temps donc et tous
les gouvernements l'ont fait de gauche
et droite depuis 25 ans donc c'est une
réforme de plus c'est tout alors après
dans 8 ans Ben selon les calculs de du
corps là l'organisme qui fait les
calculs année par année et bien on verra
s'il faut aller jusqu'à 64 ou 65 ans bon
voilà moi pour moi c'était une barre
symbolique il enlève le bar symbolique
dans la réalité ce sera le les chiffres
qui diront la vérité et donc forcément
on va travailler plus ça c'est une
certitude si l'on veut préserver les
retraites si l'on veut les baisser on
peut travailler moins alors c'est une
barre symbolique Emmanuel Blairy au fond
qu'il vient simplement de de poser on
verra bien en 2030 les choses ne sont
pas forcément figées
ce sondage 30-30
moi je ne crois pas que les choses sont
figées ainsi je pense sincèrement que
une bonne partie de lectorat de Monsieur
Mélenchon vont se porter vers la
candidate qui a le programme social ça
c'est une chose concernant les retraites
est-ce que a dit Monsieur Macron
aujourd'hui le président sortant pour
moi c'est une audible j'ai quasiment
rien compris on a l'impression que ça
s'adapte au gré des rencontres voilà on
rencontre une dame on lui pose la
question il y a juste à chaque fois faut
que ce soit beaucoup plus clair sur le
sujet nous réclamons un débat digne un
débat serein un débat projet contre
projet et là c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment clair en réalité notre côté
nous les choses sont claires elles sont
évidente c'est à dire qu'on touche pas
l'âge de la retraite c'est 62 ans et 60
ans 48t pour les gens qui en train de
commencer à travailler tôt à partir de
17 ans de 17 à 20 ans nous nous voulons
le meilleur pour les Français en réalité
voilà volonté c'est très clair
d'ailleurs je rappelle que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'était 60 ans pour tous oui
pardonnez-moi je vous laisse terminer
non mais pour revenir puisque encore une
fois je répète je peux forcément le
temps de parole comme tout le monde sur
sur on parle de gauche on parle de droit
de droite de la droite etc je vous
rappelle simplement aujourd'hui que
l'enjeu aujourd'hui il est clair ce sont
les nationaux contre les mondialistes
voilà je voulais le répéter enfin je
voulais le dire en tout cas à l'antenne
l'enjeu il est la réalité on parle pas
forcément de gauche ou de droite on
parle des nationaux contre les
mondialistes et donc en ce sens en ce
sens effectivement j'appelle tous les
patriotes français qui ont à cœur les
acquis sociaux qui veulent défendre et
qui sociaux de la France et je sais de
quoi je parle puisque c'est ça qui sont
souvent étaient des combats sur ma
circonscription ont été ici comment
dirais-je
implantés sur ma circonscription
j'appelle tous ces gens à regarder le
programme de Marine Le Pen sur la sur le
volet social voilà nous avons un
programme on entend bien les éléments
sur lesquels vous voulez insister c'est
le social et les retraites c'est très
social effectivement il touche pas un
peu juste là le député rassemblement
d'une national en disant on a du mal à
comprendre on gagne une rencontre il
change l'âge et ensuite on avance non
mais surtout enfin je vais pas revenir
sur les principes que j'ai déjà énoncé
en fait il s'est toujours les mêmes la
répartition 1100 euros minimum vous
voyez même dans le reportage on sent
bien que c'est mais oui mais de
l'incompréhension et ça demande et ça
demande rare sûrement un débat mais ce
qui est hyper important oui on veut
préserver les acquis sociaux sauf que
les acquis sociaux dans notre pays sont
fondés sur la production de valeur la
production de travail que les gens et du
travail la meilleure façon de les
protéger c'est de faire que l'on puisse
produire davantage de valeur pour mieux
la partager si on va dans le programme
que je vous promets Marine Le Pen alors
là on va voir la destruction de valeur
on va perdre la confiance de nos
investisseurs donc il y en aura moins de
travail alors là les acquis sociaux qui
sont basés sur ce de dégagement de
valeur et bien ils vont dégager aussi
donc je pense que on a la volonté de
faire que les Français s'épanouissent
mais ce n'est pas en se mettant en
dehors du monde qu'on y arrive Emmanuel
du monde quand on pose la question de
savoir à qui doivent profiter les gains
de productivité puisque un salarié
aujourd'hui produit à peu près autant
que deux salariés dans les années 80 et
donc vous êtes tous en train de dire ici
sur ce plateau que il est pas possible
comme si c'était une vérité scientifique
de travailler moins alors qu'on vit plus
longtemps et honnêtement on vit de moins
en moins plus longtemps d'ailleurs parce
que l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
stagne dans ce pays depuis maintenant
plusieurs années la question qui est
posée c'est de savoir à qui profite ses
gain de productivité ben moi j'assume de
dire qu'elle doit permettre de
travailler moins et donc moi c'est pas
63 64 65 c'est pas ça qui m'intéresse
leur proposition qui était dans le
programme de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et qui
est tout à fait réaliste et crédible et
si vous voulez qu'on organise un débat
économique sur le programme de avec
Mélenchon pas de problème on en organise
un mais il y a pas une vérité
scientifique d'un côté qui consiste à
dire qu'il y a les programmes qui sont
crédibles et ceux qui ne le sont pas ça
c'est du débat politique et on peut
l'avoir il y a pas de difficulté mais
oui Jean-Luc Mélenchon il a un programme
crédible c'est la retraite à 60 ans à
taux plein pour tout le monde maintenant
bien sûr mais comme vous m'interrogez
sur la question attendez juste une
dernière chose et après je vous laisse
poser la question suivante mais je veux
dire donc je suis en désaccord radical
avec vous mais je vais dire à Monsieur
que et aux gens qui nous écoutent que
non Madame Le Pen n'est pas la candidate
du social et du pouvoir d'achat parce
que quand on est sur l'augmentation du
SMIC et des salaires l'augmentation du
SMIC Marine Le Pen elle dit non je suis
pas pour l'augmentation du SMIC
c'est plus compliqué que ça le blocage
des prix qui est une proposition forte
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a mis dans la
campagne présidentielle Madame Le Pen a
dit non c'est pas possible je sais pas
comment on fait etc donc non Madame Le
Pen comme Monsieur Macron d'ailleurs ne
sont pas les candidats du pouvoir
d'achat et sur la démocratie alors pour
avancer terminer ce débat sur les
questions institutionnelles là vous avez
deux candidats qui proposent la
proportionnelle Marine Le Pen insistait
énormément là-dessus ce sur France Inter
les référendum elle a même parlé d'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne en
expliquant bien qu'on pourrait abroger
loi vous qui voulez révoquer même les
élus on sent bien qu'une main tendue là
non justement parce que quand une
journaliste lui a posé ce matin la
question sur la révocation des élus
Marine Le Pen a dit qu'elle n'était pas
d'accord avec la révocation des élus
donc vous voyez si vous cherchez au
moins une différence je sais que vous
n'êtes pas arbitre mais quel est le
programme qui vous semble le plus proche
du vôtre sur les questions
institutionnelles vous qui voulez une
sixième république mais moi il y a aucun
des deux programmes qui sont en lice
aujourd'hui qui me conviennent donc sur
ce volet là mais sur aucun des
partenaire on peut discuter sur tel mais
moi je suis favorable à la
proportionnelle mais je me suis
favorable à convoquer une assemblée
constituante pour passer à la Sixième
République et ça c'est une proposition
qui n'est ni dans le programme de Madame
Le Pen ni dans le programme d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'après il puisse y avoir des
points qui soient dans un des programmes
ou dans un autre mais honnêtement c'est
pas mon sujet le programme que nous
avons porté au premier tour il est pas
représenté au deuxième donc les gens qui
ont voté pour nous ils sont obligés de
faire un choix entre deux programmes qui
ne leur conviennent pas et ils font le
choix qui préparer juste et nous on leur
a dit faites pas l'erreur de donner une
voix Madame Le Pen pour le reste si on
veut appliquer notre programme le mieux
c'est de voter pour nous la prochaine
fois ou de voter pour nous aux échéances
électorales
si l'un ou l'autre des candidats
finalistes contactaient Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ou un de ses proches pour
éventuellement réfléchir à des
discussions c'est non pas de discussion
Eric Le Boucher sur le le volet
démocratique on a parlé de fatigue
démocratique on voit que l'abstention
est encore très élevée là c'est les deux
finalistes qui font des propositions
forts d'ailleurs tous les candidats en
ont parlé on ne pourra pas faire
l'économie d'une vraie réforme
institutionnelle pour mettre davantage
le citoyen au cœur de la décision non
personnellement je pense pas que ce soit
un problème institutionnel c'est un vrai
problème économique c'est un vrai
problème social on a il y a toutes les
raisons que je donne sur la montée du
populisme il y a quand même l'atrophie
de la classe moyenne la peur du
déclassement etc ce sont des problèmes
économiques sociaux ce sont pas des
problèmes institutionnels c'est pas de
changer de représentation les gilets
jaunes qui voulaient exister dans la
décision le premier temps c'est à mon
avis de réformer le capitalisme et
notamment de construire un capitalisme
européen qui soit plus redistributif et
là-dessus vous serez absolument d'accord
et donc c'est ça qui compte après le les
institutions c'est de la peinture
par-dessus dans le vrai
prononcé par par Marine Le Pen qui dit
je protégerai davantage
protectionnisme économique et le
nationalisme le protectionnisme
populiste ça échoué partout ça échouait
Trump a échoué en Angleterre ça échoué
ça échoué au Venezuela ça ne marche pas
donc si Madame Le Pen veut l'instaurer
en France ça ne marche pas il a échoué
partout le protectionnisme ce sera votre
dernière prise de parole qu'est-ce que
vous répondez avec le boucher
ça ressemble à de la voyance pourquoi
c'est échoué quel on est en France
c'est un pays mais parce que déjà la
France est un pays différent il est
incomparable de toute façon comme dirait
quelqu'un comment
bah voyons
j'ai compris non mais sincèrement voilà
je ne vois pas pourquoi j'entends ce
sera cette mesure ne sera pas applicable
ou celle-ci ne sera pas non plus mais
pour quelle raison je sais voilà on a
une conviction
c'est tout à fait possible demain de
mettre en place par exemple je reviens
sur ce que c'est mon parole qu'un petit
peu un petit peu limité sur les riches
par exemple voilà on a besoin de se
soucis
et Marine Le Pen puisque mon temps de
parole est limité Marine Le Pen
consultera le seul expert que Macron n'a
jamais consulté le peuple voilà
réellement et croyez moi que pour le
reste nous avons une volonté politique
Marine Le Pen est solide à inventé
politique elle mettra en application son
programme
merci merci Emmanuel verrerie vous
répondez pour conclure à ce représentant
du rassemblement national sur la
question référendaire ça n'est pas tabou
non plus chez Emmanuel Macron ce n'est
pas tabou et on n'a pas besoin de
refaire les institutions par contre on a
besoin de focaliser la façon dont on met
en place justement cette démocratie
délibérative plus souvent avec des
formats comme je vous disais la
convention citoyenne c'est un des un des
une des façons de l'ajouter mais on
n'est pas obligé de tout transformer par
contre moi je suis aussi voilà pour une
plus grande dose proportionnelle on a
besoin on Parlement qui avait été
promise en 2017 oui on aurait bien voulu
aller aussi également
on est un peu plus armé pour le faire
aujourd'hui cette question de la
démocratie elle est importante il faut
que ça soit aussi bien pour les plus
jeunes moi je voilà quand on participe
pas aux élections je me dis que on
laisse surtout les autres gagner et
décider de notre vie on peut pas se
contenter d'avoir une participation des
gens les plus âgés qui sont moins
concernés par l'avenir on a besoin
d'avoir aussi l'expression des jeunes et
si cette expression elle s'exprime dans
les ions de ses biens elle peut aussi
s'exprimer par d'autres formes
d'engagement et de discussions avec eux
merci merci infiniment d'être venus
débattre sur le plateau on verra ce que
ça donne du côté de vos électeurs bien
sûr dans un peu moins de 10 jours
maintenant un peu plus de 10 jours
maintenant merci à vous merci Emmanuel
Bellerive je rappelle le titre de votre
livre Éric Le Boucher échec à la
barbarie chez Grasset c'est passionnant
sur les populismes d'ici et d'ailleurs
et les moyens de retrouver un peu
d'optimisme la lumière au bout d'une
terre merci beaucoup on va présenter
notre grand témoin il était convaincu
qu'il ne reverrait pas la guerre en
Europe et ses millions de déracinés lui
le fils du Kenya de parents déportés
donc toute la vie incarne le concept de
résilience alors il s'interroge dans son
dernier livre sur les ressorts de
l'embrigadement de la servitude
volontaire on a plein de questions à
poser à Boris Cyrulnik comme les skis ce
sujet de Tibo inok
si on vous invite Boris Cyrulnik c'est
que vous nous appelez à repenser la
liberté et que la guerre au coeur de
l'Europe nous interroge et repose cette
éternelle question comment l'homme
peut-il l'utiliser cette liberté pour
faire le mal les massacres de boutcha
les crimes de cramatorzek toutes les
horreurs de la guerre russe comment tout
cela est-il possible ces questions Boris
cyruniques ont pour vous une résonance
particulière vous le fils d'un père
ukrainien et d'une mère polonaise juif
askénaz vous dont les parents sont morts
à Auschwitz vous qui avez échappé de peu
à une rafle nazi à l'âge de 6 ans voilà
pris dans un écho douloureux de
l'histoire ces images de guerre vous
pensiez que vous finiriez votre vie sans
les revoir
de ne jamais
surmonter l'impensable l'inoubliable
Boris irunique le neuropsychiatre que
vous êtes n'a eu de cesse dans ses
Essais de penser la résilience la
reconstruction comme une libération de
ces traumatismes vécus mais un autre
versant de la même vous hante aussi la
pente inverse celle de l'asservissement
et de l'embrigadement quand on est venu
une robe on peut très bien se laisser
attraper par un
escroculturel un sauveur qui va nous
dire votez pour moi je sais je connais
la solution la solution c'est ceux qui
n'ont pas la même couleur de peau c'est
les étrangers c'est les Juifs et à ce
moment-là ce sauveur va nous de redonner
l'espoir mais c'est un escroc mais cette
tentation de la soumission d'où
vient-elle de notre premier
asservissement alors bénéfique celui du
nourrisson à la mer dites-vous dès lors
ce penchant existe chez nous à
rechercher la sécurité à vouloir être
rassuré au point de nous laisser séduire
par des discours faciles des schémas
trop clair la recherche de bouc
émissaire des logiques d'embrigadement
que vous décrivez et qui sont
malheureusement d'actualité nous nous
battons contre des nationalistes et des
groupes néonazis qui utilisent des
civils pacifiques comme des boucliers
humains
se dire persécutés c'est une manière de
prendre le pouvoir
Hitler se disait persécuté par les Juifs
Poutine se dit persécuté par les
Ukrainiens faire des carrières de
victimes c'est une tentative de prise de
pouvoir parce que sa légitime notre
propre violence assez logique mortifère
Boris irunique vous opposez la liberté
et l'autonomie plus difficile à
atteindre chemin se met d'embûches de
doute et d'interrogation alors justement
Boris irunique quelques questions pour
finir quels sont les risques
d'embrigadement des temps présent
comment penser par soi-même et cette
liberté intérieure à laquelle vous nous
invitez comment la reconquérir
[Musique]
bonsoir Boris cyrully et merci beaucoup
d'être là rarement un livre n'aura
autant raisonné avec l'actualité le
laboureur ceux qui justement ont décidé
de choisir cette liberté intérieure et
ce choix à un coût et les mangeurs de
vent ceux qui sont dans la confortable
servitues c'est chez Odile Jacob on va
en parler avec la guerre en Ukraine
c'est on le voit c'est tout l'imaginaire
de la deuxième guerre mondiale qui est
réactivée alors évidemment pour vous
c'est particulier cette histoire comment
vous vous traversez tout ça comment vous
vivez depuis plus d'un mois maintenant
ces images
d'horreur d'atrocité d'exaction de
bombardements d'exode aussi
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale j'étais
convaincu de ne jamais revoir des images
comme ça convaincus de ne jamais
entendre des discours pareil des
arguments pareil et 80 ans plus tard
j'entends les mêmes mots j'ouvre les
mêmes images comme si la mémoire ne
servait à rien et ça c'est très
douloureux ça veut dire aussi que
l'histoire se répète et qu'on a rien
appris ça veut dire qu'on a rien appris
la mémoire ne sert à rien c'est comme si
on n'avait jamais tenu compte de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et des guerres
précédentes on n'y a jamais réfléchi et
on retrouve les mêmes mécanismes que
dans les années 30
années 30 il y avait ceux qui avaient du
mal à rester eux-mêmes un art d'autre
qui avait du mal à penser par eux-mêmes
et les gens se laissaient embarquer par
un courant d'idées qu'ils adoptait
auquel ils croyait auquel il se
soumettait sans juger c'est-à-dire que
ça donne une confortable servitude on
n'a pas besoin de faire d'efforts pour
penser il suffit d'être
de scander les mêmes slogans ça donne
une sensation d'euphorie et ça soumet
complètement à une impression une
illusion de comprendre qui mène à la
tragédie que l'Europe n'avait pas ce
pouvoir de nous prémunir de la guerre la
garantie de paix alors j'étais convaincu
que on avait ce pouvoir et bien je me
suis trompé on n'a pas ce pouvoir je
pense quand même je continue à penser
que quand cette guerre sera finie parce
que les guerres finissent toujours mais
après un massacre après un coup
exorbitant je pense que quand cette
guerre sera finie il faudra remettre en
place des mécanismes de liberté
intérieure c'est-à-dire de choix de
l'école l'université les artistes le
cinéma les romans tout ce qui peut
inviter à se décentrer de soi pour se
représenter le monde d'un autre une
autre couleur une autre culture une
autre religion une autre pensée c'est
passionnant mais on est passionné à
condition d'abord été sécurisé or quand
on est insécurisé par une catastrophe
économique par une catastrophe
culturelle par maintenant on se rend
compte que finalement les catastrophes
culturelles et les catastrophes
naturelles c'est souvent la même chose
et sans doute un tri
intriguéphes la tentation de la
servissement
est très grande l'embragadement on a
besoin presque de se donner un dictateur
mais oui c'est à dire que parce que ce
dictateur est un escroculturel qui a le
qui en attribue on lui laisse prendre le
pouvoir de nous sécuriser donc il nous
vend ce qu'on espère de la sécurité et
puis ensuite on paye mais quand on est
vulnérabilisé qu'on soit enfant qu'on
soit adulte ou qu'on soit un groupe
social quand on est vulnérabilisé par un
accident de la vie ou de la nature ou de
la culture on a besoin de se sécuriser
et on retrouve le mécanisme archaïque
qui nous sécurisé c'est-à-dire les bras
de la mer sauf que là les bras de la mer
c'est
certaines façons est-ce que vous qui
avez traversé vous avez bossé beaucoup
travaillé sur la mécanique du
totalitarisme sur ces ressorts est-ce
que c'est lui qui incarne le
totalitarisme du 21e siècle aujourd'hui
de Vladimir Poutine il a un discours
totalitaire je sais d'où vient le mal
lancer les Ukrainiens mais avant c'était
les Syriens avant c'était les Géorgiens
avant c'était donc il trouve toujours un
bouc émissaire je sais d'où vient le mal
réinstant réinsteront la eu un pouvoir
fort et tout sera réglé donc le via le
mal aujourd'hui vient du ukrainiens et
creusant les ukrainiens et on sera
heureux c'est exactement le discours
d'Hitler Hitler disait donner
et obéissez moi faites ce que je vous
dis réciter mes idées
par slogan par mouvement populaire et
vous allez donner 1000 ans de bonheur à
la supérieur c'est à dire les blancs aux
yeux bleus
c'est un discours totalitaire comme il y
en a eu d'autres je voudrais qu'on parle
de cette tentation de la soumission vous
expliquer très bien que elle s'origine
dans les bras de la mer dans ce cocon
maternel au fond dont on a besoin pour
vivre pour se construire cette sécurité
de base pour ensuite trouver cette
liberté intérieure mais si on leur
rapporte à notre histoire comment vous
expliquer que Le Chambon-sur-Lignon par
exemple ou Dieu le fit résiste en France
refuse la collaboration comment vous
expliquer qu'ailleurs au contraire il y
a les ailés de la collaboration qui qui
mène au pire alors Dieu le fit le maire
était pétainiste c'est-à-dire que la
population avait élu un maire pétainiste
et que la population était indignée par
les Juifs qui voulaient prendre le
pouvoir et par c'était le discours de
l'aide de l'époque mais quand ils ont vu
arriver 2000 Juifs belges c'était plus
le Juif qui veut prendre le pouvoir
c'était monsieur bloomantal qui est
sympathique monsieur Goldstein qui
m'exaspère c'était les êtres humains et
dans ce cas le maire pétainiste a pris
chez lui un cachet chez lui 4 ou 5
enfants qui n'avaient plus leurs parents
juifs psychologique alors
neuropsychiatrie qu'est-ce qui active un
ressort chez un être et plutôt qu'un
autre c'est parce que ce maire
pétainiste a été ému par la vraie
rencontre de l'autre comme un laboureur
on peut aimer un tel on peut détester un
tel comme dans la vie quotidienne alors
qu'auparavant il s'était soumis non pas
en réel il s'était soumis l'idée qui se
faisait du réel c'est-à-dire une
représentation si on élimine les Juifs
tout ira bien il y a aussi ces pays qui
regardent l'Ukraine impuissant et ces
populations nous regardons l'Ukraine
mourir avec ce sentiment presque de
culpabilité
qui ronge même s'il y a de la solidarité
même si on accueille des réfugiés
comment on fait pour vivre avec ça ce
sentiment d'impuissance et de
culpabilité mais ça s'est produit dans
les années 30 avec la guerre civile en
Espagne c'est un mouvement un
gouvernement socialiste qui a refusé
d'envoyer l'armée et qui a mal reçu les
républicains espagnols qui ont été mis
dans des camps ils ont été mal reçu donc
je pense que c'est un processus qui se
répète parce que probablement on a
commis une faute d'éducation et de
culture il faut absolument il me semble
présenter la culture des autres c'est un
épanouissement mais on ne peut éprouver
le plaisir de découvrir une autre
religion une autre culture on ne sait
d'un plaisir ce plaisir d'exploration on
ne peut la voir que si auparavant on a
été sécurisé et cette sécurité on
l'obtient dans les bras de la mer avec
le père beaucoup plus tôt que ce qu'on
croyait parce que avant on disait le
père intervient pour plus tard pour
de cette fusion initiale pour empêcher
les
la toute puissance maternelle disait-on
à cette époque-là auront se rend compte
maintenant que des observations de
neurologie et de psychologie montrent
que la présence des Pères est importante
beaucoup plus tôt la femme est sécurisée
et une mère sécurisée devient
sécurisante pour son bébé et qui est-ce
qui peut sécuriser la mer c'est celui
avec qui avec qui elles ont fait vous
nous dites aussi d'une certaine façon
que cet exercice de sécurisation n'est
pas que familiale qu'une société doit
aussi prendre cette part et l'école est
une doit être une ouverture d'esprit
alors si d'abord les mers sont
inévitables parce que on est tous nés
d'une femme donc les mers sont
inévitables et c'est la base de sécurité
primordiale et très tôt il y a une autre
base de sécurité qu'on appelle le père
sauf que avec dans la culture moderne on
a de plus en plus de mal à dire qui est
le père est-ce que c'est un homme est-ce
que c'est un amant est-ce que c'est de
la grand-mère quand la femme est séparée
qu'elle élève son enfant avec sa propre
mère c'est la grand-mère qui fait
fonction de père quand c'est un couple
de femmes homosexuels qui est la mère
qui est une fonction symbolique et pas
forcément
incarné par le sexe masculin et nos
enfants en France qui entendent ce mot
de guerre toute la journée qu'est-ce
qu'on leur dit comment on fait alors ça
dépend de l'âge du développement de
l'enfant si c'est un bébé
préverbal il faut que la mer soit
sécurisée par sa famille par le Père par
la culture par ses copains si la mère
est sécurisée l'enfant se débrouillera
il va pas avoir accès à l'homo guerre ça
veut rien dire pour lui si l'enfant
commence à parler il est important de
parler autour de l'enfant en souriant en
disant voilà il y a un problème on
appelle ça la guerre mais on sait ce
qu'il faut faire pour s'en protéger donc
là l'enfant sera sécurisé par des mots
il n'en peut seulement par un contact et
ce n'est que après l'âge de depuis 8 ans
quand l'enfant a accès au récit à cause
de son développement neurologique il a
accès au temps la représentation du
temps et là il a accès à la filiation et
là c'est l'histoire le sens la
philosophie c'est là que c'est que là on
a on doit donner sens à ce qui arrive et
expliquer bavarder avec les enfants et
leur dire qu'est-ce que tu penses ce que
j'ai fait avec les enfants soldats quand
j'étais au Congo ce qu'est ce que tu
penses de la guerre c'est les enfants
qui jugés c'est les enfants qui
apprenaient à juger donc ça dépend du
stade de développement merci c'est
passionnant vous dites aussi c'est pour
terminer ma dernière question que nous
sommes dans un désert de sens ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir renouer avec des
grands récits à toute à tous les niveaux
familial dans les dans l'école au niveau
politique alors le problème des grands
récits c'est qu'ils sont tous
dynamisants protecteurs et exaltant et
dangereux c'est à dire que le nazi
mettait un grand récit et vous aurez
1000 ans de bonheur
de religion provoquée des grands récits
le communisme c'était les lendemains qui
chantent tous ces grands récits étaient
très beaux et menaient la tragédie mené
à la guerre donc je pense qu'il est se
retrouver en soi c'est la liberté
intérieure dont vous parlez alors voilà
mais je ne peux donner sens que si un
autre je ne peux penser par moi-même que
s'il y a une à la pensée d'un autre si
je suis seul je peux pas passer par
moi-même j'ai besoin de la pensée d'un
autre pour juger évaluer et là j'ai
acquis un degré de liberté intérieure je
viens de citer un arrante merci beaucoup
merci infiniment Boris unique le
laboureur et les mangeurs devant vous
vous est venu cette idée des cette
expression des mangeurs de
ventes
heureux ils n'ont rien à faire il suffit
de déglutir tout ce qu'on leur raconte
ils sont obèses comme sur la couverture
ils sont heureux c'est la confortable
servitude
merci infiniment Boris cy allez on va
passer au scan après donc vous restez
avec moi si vous ne voulez bien c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos chroniqueurs
pour passer au crible cette entre deux
tours de la présidentielle
[Musique]
mais avant les drones il y a les deux
mots
et bien moi je vous propose le rouge
d'allemand d'agir pour le climat
l'assimilation
la République c'est moi la France orange
macronique
travailleuse travailleur le système vous
exclut il y a un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la France sa
grandeur c'est le vol
et de tous les jours de chroniqueurs
nous ont rejoint sur ce plateau Stéphane
blackowski et son carnet de campagne
dans un instant et j'aurais mis Baudot
de France Info la radio la télé pour
nous parler de la toute nouvelle affiche
de campagne de Marine Le Pen sur quoi
sur qui votre œil s'est arrêté
aujourd'hui Stéphane
9h57 tweet est tombé le président
Sarkozy tout l'ex-président c'est
d'exprimer alors on se demandait
pourquoi Nicolas Sarkozy n'avait jamais
soutenu Valérie Pécresse pendant la
campagne on a compris dimanche on sait
pourquoi
4,78% c'est ça la raison pour laquelle
il n'a pas soutenu donc jamais un mot en
faveur de Pécresse et là d'un seul coup
on apprend qu'il va voter Macron c'est
pas franchement une surprise non c'est
pas une surprise vous savez que Valérie
Pécresse a constamment dans la campagne
dit qu'on lui avait vu que Macron lui
avait volé son programme donc voter
Macron voter Pécresse est-ce que c'est
vraiment très différent là où c'est le
pavé dans la mare c'est que Nicolas
Sarkozy dit exactement le contraire de
ce qu'on dit hier les républicains qui
s'étaient réunies pour trouver une
position commune donc il y a 130 membres
au bureau politique donc ça c'est le
collectif et la seule menthe 13 qui se
sont abstenus et tous les autres étaient
d'accord pour tomber sur une déclaration
commune ciselée aux mots près pour être
sûr de ne fâcher personne garder l'unité
si bien que même Christian Jacob qui a
donc répondu aux questions quand tu l'as
demandé vous pouvez nous rappeler votre
position il a pas voulu répondre
spontanément et moi la déclaration
regarde
ce site tu peux me la ressortir je
retrouve plus voilà voilà c'est bon
notre notre famille politique a toujours
été reste un adversaire déterminé au
rassemblement national aucune voie ne
peut se porter sur Marine Le Pen son
projet politique et économique nous
conduirait au cas où voilà je voyais
sourire attention
pas mais possible à ce niveau là alors
Nicolas Sarkozy a mis les pieds dans le
plat bah oui
législatives au moins rester unis
jusqu'à cette échéance électorale
puisque ils ont sans poste au Parlement
ils aimeraient bien en garder les plus
grandes parties mais comme le disait
déjà Édouard Philippe la poutre
travaille il le disait il y a 5 ans
quand il a rejoint Macron et donc la
poutre a continué de travailler on se
demande voilà ça craque très très fort
on a l'impression qu'elle va céder et
que la maison va finalement tomber sur
la tête des républicains là ça va
arriver là pour l'avenir de la droite
les républicains
il a soufflé sur la maison des
socialistes en 2007 il a mangé les
petits cochons de gauche et là il
souffle sur la maison des républicains
et les petits cochons de droite doivent
se méfier parce qu'il pourrait bien
s'accroquer eux aussi évidemment ils ont
quand même un ancrage local les
républicains mais oui mais c'est ce que
répétait Christian Jacob hier il disait
qu'il y a eu des idées peut-être non il
y a quand même un petit problème de
politique on va dire chez les
républicains parce que
Eric Ciotti lui a refusé de valider ce
vote ce texte commun il s'est abstenu
parce que le texte disait pas une voix
pour Marine Le Pen et lui son slogan ça
serait plutôt pas une voix pour Emmanuel
Macron
personnellement je ne voterai pas
Emmanuel Macron parce que si ce soir
nous avons ce chaos dans le pays quelque
part s'il y a autant de votes
contestataire de protestation c'est
qu'il a échoué en tant que président de
la République et je le dis très
clairement je ne me reconnais pas dans
sa politique je ne me reconnais pas dans
son bilan et je ne le soutiendrai pas
donc je dis c'est quand même le mec qui
arrive en tête aux primaire et qui
disait je préfère être tes amours que
Macron donc il y a quand même un quart
des gens de chez la républicains qui
sont un peu de sur ce tandis que
Jean-François Copé alors là c'est tout
le contraire
mais ils ne veulent pas le même cap
avoue que ça pose un problème un moment
ils vont à mon avis pas pouvoir rester
unis très longtemps quand on entend
Jean-François copié ce matin je les
infos c'est ce qu'on se dit
vois avec tristesse LR ce qu'il en reste
un ce fourvoyer en assumant pas de
s'opposer très fortement à l'extrême
droite et donc de voter Macron même le
mot extrémisme a été enlevé tellement on
avait peur de choquer c'est vous dire et
malgré tout ça Éric se dit il a quand
même pas voté le truc donc c'est vous
dire l'état quand même de d'absence de
leadership dans lequel on est donc je me
tourne vers Boris j'ai eu un de vos
livres d'expliquer que les hommes
avaient peut-être imité la hiérarchie
des loups dans la meute qu'il fallait un
mâle alpha parce que en tout cas chez
les loups s'il y a pas de mal alpha les
mâles finissent par centre dévorer donc
je pense qu'on a ce problème là chez les
chez les républicains il manque un Mac
alpha ils vont finir par centre dévorer
non
oui c'est pour ça qu'il faut un ordre
mais quand l'ordre est totalité c'est
l'ordre des cimetières rien ne bouge on
n'a pas le droit de penser rien ne bouge
donc il faut un ordre il faut pouvoir le
contester c'est la définition de la
démocratie donc chez les républicains on
en est pas quand même assez tordre on en
est pas là
quand même
d'attendre le deuxième tour de pas avoir
soutenu sa famille oui mais je me
demande si la politique n'est pas
cruelle
on est peut-être encore un peu trop naïf
alors on enchaîne avec une image
dévoilée aujourd'hui j'aurais mis vous
passez au scan de la nouvelle affiche de
campagne de Marine Le Pen affiche de
second tour où l'on découvre une Marine
Le Pen seul dans un décor sobre en appui
sur un bureau veste bleu marine sourire
aux lèvres c'est presque tout si ce
n'est voyez ce slogan pour tous les
Français slogans basique simple efficace
a priori rassembleur l'ensemble est
solennel aux allures présidentielles car
oui ça va me rappelle peut-être quelque
chose une image qui est évidemment une
autre c'est un copier-coller du portrait
officiel d'Emmanuel Macron copier-coller
rechercher et assumer même par les
équipes de Marine Le Pen une volonté
évidemment de ce présidentialiser Marine
Le Pen est seul à l'image un slogan mais
rien d'autre non c'est l'aboutissement
de moi et d'année ou Marine Le Pen à
gommé tout ce qui pouvait elle a ramené
à son passé à son histoire à son nom son
affiche précédente souvenez-vous déjà
elle s'appelait uniquement marine ça
c'est un artifice qu'elle a qu'elle
utilise souvent et puis même si on
remonte dans le temps on a vu le moment
où elle avait gommé donc son nom son
parti les logos donc là la même donné
son prénom comme ça c'est plus facile le
bureau vide derrière elle c'est
quasiment une manière d'illustrer la
table rurale
voilà bref c'est Gomez gomégomé enlever
les irritants ce qui peut d'ailleurs
porter à débat ou à rappeler les les
racines programmatiques du rassemblement
national du Front national de l'extrême
droite en général non sur les étrangers
le voile l'Europe sa relation avec la
Russie tout ça non c'est une photo bien
propre et bien rangée une petite
médaille de baptême quand même c'est
comme une un signe je sais pas si
ostentatoire mais moi je lis mes tailles
de baptême parce que j'ai une culture
catholique mais c'est peut-être autre
chose c'est peut-être Maurice finalement
elle essaye de faire oublier qui elle
est ça peut marcher à votre avis de
gommer au fond tout chez de Le Pen chez
marine oui elle se travaille une belle
image c'est à dire qu'elle a une image
de femme forte et paisible elle parle en
souriant effectivement elle dit rien de
fait qu'il fâche donc elle cherche des
amis je me demande pourquoi entretenir
pour entretenir le flou oui
diabolisation éviter tout ce qui peut
déplaire sans dévoiler son jeu se
montrer plus présentable c'est un long
travail de fond pour adoucir son image
pour par exemple aussi adoucir ses
relations avec la presse mais parfois le
naturel revient au galop extrait d'une
conférence de presse aujourd'hui elle
parlait gouvernance elle parlait
démocratie et au moment même où elle
parle de démocratie elle assume
tranquillement de décider qui est
journaliste et qui ne l'est pas
donc c'est moi qui ai décidé il y a
plusieurs années de cela que quotidien
était une émission de divertissement et
que par conséquent je ne me sentais pas
obligé
d'accréditer quotidien et vous madame
qui est le journaliste ou pas
vous savez je suis chez moi donc dans
mon QG je suis chez moi dans mon QG elle
finit par un rire un peu gras une
attitude qui nous rappelle un peu la
Marine Le Pen d'avant son grand
ripolinage alors on pense que ce qu'on
veut des méthodes et d'ailleurs de parce
qu'en fait en l'occurrence il est
question de l'émission quotidien mais ça
n'est pas un rappel le dirigeant
politique de décider qui est journaliste
qui n'est pas enfin pas un dirigeant qui
se veut démocrate et qui aspire à
diriger un pays où la presse est libre
on gommer le naturel il revient au galop
Boris et réunique quand on commence à
vouloir choisir des journalistes c'est
pas bon exactement c'est un des premiers
signes de dictatures c'est-à-dire que la
la première chose que font les
dictateurs c'est d'attaquer les
immeubles de télévision alors les
journalistes qui se soumettent en une
promotion et les autres ils sont
rééduquer torturés exilés assassinés il
y en a eu qui ont été pas mal assassinés
donc les journalistes et les artistes
sont les premières cibles des dictateurs
merci beaucoup merci Jean-Rémy Baudot
merci beaucoup Stéphane Boris Cyrulnik
le laboureur et les mangeurs devant
sécher Odile Jacob ça va très bien
marché comme tout comme tous vos livres
jusqu'à présent très belle soirée
documentaire à présent un film sur le
Burkina Faso un village tébélé suivi
d'un débat sur la présence française au
Sahel très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]